I am Kumail Nanjiani and this is
actually me it's the front for this
Kumail Nanjiani uses computer science
degree in Silicon Valley absolutely not
no idea what's going on I pretend to
type on the computer and they have a
thing set up so that it fills in as it
goes I did have a computer job after
graduating college but I was very bad at
it
I would tell people to restart their
computers a lot I remember some terms
JavaScript HTML hard drives motherboards
keyboards power adapters memory delete
key can I take this one again yes I use
my computer science degree Oh Silicon
Valley's the single most important thing
in my life
submit because I hit the enter button
IMDB one of my trivia is is a huge fan
of Hugh Grant true so far he decided to
start a stand-up career after being
impressed by grants performance in Four
Weddings and a funeral yes that is true
his best man speech at the beginning of
Four Weddings and a funeral maybe want
to be a stand-up and I basically was
copying his delivery from that one scene
for the first solid five years of my
career Hugh Grant has no idea so Google
grant was kemal submit what did to meld
on Jionni first think of the US when he
moved here from Pakistan that's from
Chora and the two tags are Kumail
Nanjiani and us-pakistan relations that
seems you're really overstating the
import of your question here well first
came to the US I went to Iowa and that
was very different from the America that
I'd seen because I'd seen movies and
that's Los Angeles in New York
I thought America was very quiet but
there were a lot of farms but it smelled
like alfalfa and then everybody was very
friendly I remember that
also the de portions of food were huge I
remember when I first got to college it
was orientation and the only students
who were there
for the international students which was
me and the only other kids that were
there was the football team and so I
remember standing in line for food and
it was just like these gigantic men in
front of me and I was like oh wow
everyone here is way bigger than I am
because in Pakistan I was one of the
taller people and then I was standing
behind these guys and their legs were
bigger than my waist and I was like this
is bad for my confidence anyway have not
fully recovered submit the comedian at
18 he moved to the United States and
attended Grinnell College in Iowa from
which he graduated in 2001 he completed
a double major in computer science and
philosophy that is all exactly true in
2019 Nanjiani will co-star and men in
black International which will be
released on June 14 2019 that is true I
play an alien so you won't see my face
but you'll hear my voice I'm a little
alien frog lizard thing Nanjiani will
also star in the action comedy Stuber
which is set for release on July 12 2019
that is also true that's me and Dave
Bautista that movie will be out July 12
2019 it's great watch it Twitter where
can I find love like kuma land and Emily
V Gordon I don't know I just got very
lucky new stand-up comedy and get
heckled by the love of your life that's
a good start that is how we met I was
doing stand-up and she heckled me and
then I tried to look for after the show
but she was embarrassed and she left the
next night ran into her someone she did
turned me down but we exchanged phone
numbers and then a couple days later
Street accent what she was like do you
want to get a platonic dinner and I said
sure I know what that means
so do that click Fred asks are you more
fit than ever I love the beard really
like Fred he's [ __ ] on it thank you
on the beard I am NOT more fit than ever
the most fit I was was literally right
when I met Emily I was like working out
all the time as soon as I met Emily out
okay I can start eating french fries
again I've made a resolution I will be
more fit than ever this year so ask me
in six months Submit
I know you are super busy with your
Hollywood stuff and I wish you the best
that sounds sarcastic I wish you the
best but you have any plans to make
indoor kids or guests on harmontown
again soon your podcast fans miss your
voice I will definitely be back on
harmontown indoor kids it was a more
complicated question because Emily and I
do that together but definitely want to
do one final episode and I talk to Emily
all the time about it
if I had to bet I would say yes we will
do at least one more episode Kingdom
Hearts was the first game to make me cry
what video games have caused strong
emotions for you when I was a kid on my
Super Nintendo at a game called Secret
of Mana and it was very hard to find in
Pakistan and I got it and I loved it and
I hadn't beaten it and my friend was
like can I borrow it for a couple days
and I gave it to him and then he claimed
that thieves broke into his house tied
him up and stole the game I don't know
if that really happened but like he made
me cry because I lost it Submit I feel
like pizza often steals nachos thunder
are we agreed are you singing the nachos
are better than pizza
that's so [ __ ] crazy nothing against
nachos but if not just sit there they
get soggy and inedible you have to eat
nachos within like 10 minutes of them
being made where it's pizza
I mean cold pizzas a thing you can eat
pizza later you can heat it up I can't
believe I'm even talking about this it's
so obvious that pizza is better than
nachos
so no Michael truly we are not agreed
next reddit what is Pakistani Denzel I
am Pakistani Denzel the question should
be who is Pakistani Denzel so this is
from an episode of Silicon Valley season
1 I said you know in Pakistan I called
her Pakistani Gisele which is crazy
because in Pakistan they would just call
me Denzel and it made it into the show
and it's stuck it's sort of been
referenced every year in increasingly
more sarcastic terms on the show which
I'm not thrilled about but I am
Pakistani is el submitted in
what's your favorite parmigiana
this is gonna be controversial it's not
my favorite kind of sandwich it's too
much I think cuz I think the chicken is
fried and then this mozzarella and then
there's marinara it's too messy I don't
like messy foods like I love burgers but
if the burgers too messy I won't [ __ ]
with it like if I get something on my
clothes it ruins my whole day I love
unhealthy food whenever I eat it I
really feel like it's hanging out for a
while and they don't like tomatoes on my
sandwiches just like a wet cold thing in
there you know things so my favorite
kind of parmigiana is one that's not
sorry more Twitter why do you make that
face all the time now feels like a very
aggressive question I did read an
interview with Hugh Grant where he said
that he doesn't like smiling inside
honestly didn't smile on pictures for a
long time and now I'm trying to smile
while also controlling the urge to not
smile but I could sort of do the warm
with my eyebrows I did practice it a lot
as a kid it was like maybe I was 12 and
I was like this is how I can get girls
also is then a small dingus while you
make that face all the time now why do
you love a small dingus
I think he's pretty bulletproof I don't
know I can't make fun of him because
he's already gone there next Kamel it's
late and I want to watch the x-files
which episode is your favorite so my
favorite episode of the x-files is an
episode called Clyde Brockman's final
repose but if you're not a big x-files
person that's not the first episode you
should watch if you're a fan of the
x-files and you also are okay with
horror stuff that's Gary there's an
episode called home that is one of my
favorite x-files episodes
it's only aired like once or twice on TV
because so many people complain but it's
a really good episode
I've watched but many times submit so
apparently at some point I tweeted
bananas are the Beatles of fruit and
someone said as if not as good as
everyone wants you to believe I honestly
don't know what I meant by that I
I only know the Beatles that well but I
do think bananas are the best like
utility fruit I think that they're
completely underrated because they come
in their own covering you can eat them
quickly
most people open bananas from the stem
side monkeys open bananas from the other
side and it's actually way better and
you have a little handle to hold it with
I don't ever say monkeys do it so you
should but I would say they are the
authority of bananas so I also want to
say one other underrated fruit is
prepare I don't think enough people talk
about pears they don't get enough credit
pears or if apples will good all the
time
pears are like if Apple's gave a [ __ ]
you know next
can you ellipses can you believe like
this person had to like pull themselves
together and so if I do really do it I
had to go can you can you believe there
are people in the world who don't like
mango no I cannot believe that mango is
the best by far and if people don't like
mango they haven't had the right mango I
can't believe there are people who don't
like mango you know my brother doesn't
like mango he's a piece of [ __ ]
submitting thank you guys for watching
that was actually me